on attendait la réponse des russes aux
propositions américaines il faudra donc
encore un peu s'armer de patience le
kremlin et le chef de la diplomatie
russe ont tour à tour réagi ce matin à
la lettre américaine on en parle avec
vous julienne calling bonjour notre
correspondant à moscou les russes pas
vraiment satisfait c'est peu de le dire
juge la réponse américaine totalement
inacceptable
bon en tout cas le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov effectivement ce
matin a réagi en disant que la première
réaction peut être immédiate c'est de
dire que voilà le les intérêts russes
c'est là le point de vue russe en
réalité sur sa propre sécurité n'est pas
du tout prise en compte encore une fois
par l'otan est à washington dans ses
réponses mais le kremlin a également
précisé que cela prendra du temps il
faut le temps que tous les différents
ministères notamment la défense par
exemple russie ministère des affaires
étrangères également et le kremlin avait
bien analysé réponse américaine plus en
détail avant de donner des réponses plus
claires et que ça devrait arriver
peut-être en début de semaine prochaine
par la voix du président poutine
lui-même mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
vous là sans surprise bien sûr le du
côté de l'otan il n'y a aucun pas de
fait vers cette ligne rouge russe vers
cette demande la plus importante pour la
russie qui est bien sûr la non extension
de l'otan plus à l'est et surtout une
adhésion potentiel bien sûr de l'ukraine
vous le disiez et là dessus évidemment
les deux positions restent encore
extrêmement ferme la russie semble c'est
vraiment pour la russie le point de
friction numéro un en fait effectivement
sergueï lavrov s'est également les
ministères le ministre faisait face
étrangères russe a également réagi à la
mi journée ici si internet du de son
ministère en disant que bien pour lui le
temps une fois de plus et washington
faisait un peu ce qui leur pose comme
bon leur semblait et penser uniquement
la sécurité du bloc occidental et pas du
tout à la sécurité des autres blocs et
des autres membres on va dire qu'ils
font pas partie de l'otan et donc que si
et c'est bien sûr inacceptable pour
moscou lavrov qui précise tout de même
que d'autres points secondaires
peut-être un peu moins important pour la
russie comme par exemple les
déploiements des missiles ou les
exercices militaires des deux côtés
serait peut-être potentiellement
d'autres points de compromis trouvable
mais que voilà encore une fois sur le
point le plus essentiel pour moscou qui
est le temps il n'y a pour l'instant
aucune avancée
concrètes et palpables et donc cela
ouvre sans doute une nouvelle séquence
diplomatique une fois de plus sergueï
lavrov et anthony blinken vont sans
doute se rencontrer à nouveau ou en tout
cas se parler sur les semaines à venir
pour l'instant sur le front militaire
c'est encore un stand by également et
voilà vous disiez on a encore tout début
d'un processus qui est sans doute va
être extrêmement long et difficile
âpre et disputée et on n'est pas du tout
sûr que aucun point de convergence se
retrouver sur les semaines à venir
malheureusement merci beaucoup je vis en
direct de moscou au moment où l'on se
parle réactions allemandes sur ce
dossier craignant à berlin on tiens ta à
mettre en garde les russes les sanctions
contre la russie viseront le gazoduc
north stream 2 en cas d'attaqué vous
savez c'est l'un des des enjeux 1
derrière cette crise